Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Byrd is time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 14th, 2015. What's going on?
How, uh, I'm a New York
City. It's Sunday night.
Uh,
eight 24 left in the third quarter.
Knowing when patriots first to
Houston fucking technicians. Uh,
I am in New York City to, uh, promote.
Finally the fucking,
uh,
we're finally putting out F is for family.
I know I've been talking about this shit,
but I got to do it tomorrow.
I got to do, I'm doing, I'm
fucking media boy, monkey boy.
Going to be fucking going all over town
and all over that on the fucking phone
and all that shit.
Talking about this wonderful new
show that we have a coming out.
So if you guys can do something for me,
I would really appreciate
it by watching it.
December eight teeth on Netflix there.
I got it out of the way.
All right. Um, and any
ways, and also thank you for
everybody who watched the, uh,
the pie crust video, Huh? Oh,
Billy Baker got over 600,000 hits,
you know,
and I learned some shit.
Some people like don't use CRESCO,
you should use fucking Lod. And you know,
it's funny, it was somebody bought me,
got me a thing of lard and
I keep forgetting to use it,
so I'm going to try that next time.
And then also people set a better way
to pick up the pie crust is your fucking
slowly roll it over with the uh,
the rolling pin.
I didn't know either one of those,
but the guy who told me,
I read it on some fucking
website, he just goes, oh bill,
Bill, Bill, Bill, Bill. Like 20 bills.
You were doing so well. The, the,
the just say to you, fuck. You know,
so you know how to pick up a
fucking pie crust better than I do.
Why don't you just fucking
tell me how to do it?
Why do you gotta to act like the
fucking sky just fell. It didn't,
my pie cross came out fine.
Everybody is such a fucking cunt.
You know,
what amazes me about adult is that whole
fucking thing that he just did. Oh,
Bill. Bill, Bill. You
know what that really is?
That is literally his fucking inner child.
Literally going,
mommy, mommy, mommy, mommy. Look at me.
I know how to do it better. It's like,
just fucking grow up.
Am I being a Katrina?
I don't think I am. Oh, Jesus is showing
the fucking highlights of the Patriots.
Special teams.
So fumbled another fucking punt.
Gave these jerk off Texans and
other, no, that chance here.
I'll tell you right now, I don't buy JJ
watts intensity. I just don't buy it.
I think he's just hammered it
up for the fucking cameras.
He's got a fucking scowl on his
face before the game even starts.
You know what I made? What are you mad
at? Jumping Jacks. Touching your toes.
That's stupid.
Fucking commercial with a blue grass band.
Starts spraying water on his face and
then he yells at his locker and then
there's nobody there. I get it.
He gets up for games. You know?
Gimme Ray Lewis. Anytime. I would rather
have ray Lewis screaming and yelling.
You know what I mean?
Did that fucking supersized astronaut at.
Gotcha.
I've just fucking with you. He's a great
player and I'm so psyched. Half his hand,
his fucking one of his
hands is wrapped up.
Thank God we would have been
in fucking trouble this game.
Hopefully you're not sitting there with
some fucking caddy to canary smile on
your face knowing that I'm going to do
the rest of this podcast watching the
Patriots somehow blow a 14 point lead. I
know that's not going to happen, right?
Get Out. Ah, you fucking
cunts over the middle.
Um, so anyways, I uh,
I got here on Thursday.
I've been doing some stand up,
um,
getting ready for these talk
shows and Shit I got to do,
I'm doing a tonight show,
Jimmy Fallon on a Tuesday
and then Wednesday I'm in
La Doing Conan and then I'm
on fucking, I'm officially
on God damn vacation. But um,
I had a great week, dude. Had a great
time being back here in New York.
It is unsettlingly warm.
The only thing more scary about how
fucking warm it is back here is people's
reaction to it.
They fucking love it.
These east coast people have to take
it it in the face old man winter every
fucking year day.
You know,
the overwhelming response to global
warming up to this point is like,
yeah, bring it on. I'm
loving this. I literally,
I saw a woman and a fucking half shirt,
not a half shirt.
She had a belly show and like
she was going to be a dancer,
bind a one of them fucking chicks.
It can't really sing, you know,
and they use the auto tone since they
got to show their tits a little bit,
you know,
showed the little naughty little bits a
little better than naughty bits. Right?
She's walking down the street and
I'm like, I was like, oh my God.
When I saw she was gorgeous, then
I was just thinking like, dude,
it's four and have the fucking half.
I was like, this is December 10th.
She's walking down the
street like it's uh,
April applause of leave in May.
And um,
I was, I, you know, so
then I went on stage.
I was joking about it at the stand in
this fucking lady in the front row.
Just all she could talk about, she was
just nodding and nodding and nodding.
I was just going,
you know,
you realize just how fucking
cities going to look like Venice,
it's going to be underwater. Right.
And she was just going like, yeah,
I know what I love. So whether
it's just it's over, it's fucking,
I, I have, I am convinced
of it. It's fucking over.
People will choose that convenience right
in front of their face and they won't
see the volcano fuck interrupted.
You know, in the distance.
They don't give a fuck if in that
moment they hand in the face is going to
fucking be more soothing.
That's what the fuck they gonna
look at and who's getting no,
I don't have any solutions and a
part of the problem, but at least,
at least this is the
only thing I could say.
At least I have the decency to be afraid
I'm not,
I'm not
doing anything about it.
I'm trying to eat less fish.
I feel bad for the base board.
Am I going to do?
Just me walking around being alive.
I'm contributing to this shit.
Not a mention of flying halfway across
the fucking slowly across the country to
promote a fucking cartoon. Get on the
ball. That's a live ball. Fuck you.
That's not an incomplete pass.
Fuck you.
Oh,
you fucking bastards.
Okay.
Anyways, um, now they're saying
now that having a discussion,
now they have a discussion.
What happened? He went back out.
It's clearly an incomplete. Ah, I duNno.
This is going to be one
of the ones that it,
he stopped his hand motion going forward.
He stopped the throwing motion
and grip the fucking ball.
Yeah.
These stupid fucking replace in the
NFL. You know, going to the, uh,
the video booth.
This is like,
yeah,
it turned all of these moments like this.
This is why I hate NBA basketball.
Yeah.
Is the timeout, the timeout, the timeout.
How fucking long it takes. By the way,
congratulations to the Golden
State Warriors winning 28
fucking games in a row.
I don't think that, that, I'm trying to
think of what that could ever be broken.
I mean that's, that is insane. And as
much as they didn't break the Lakers,
um, the, their record,
that was still amazing and I wish I
could actually have watched the fucking
double overtime game against the Celtics
and it looked like an instant classic.
Of course I was out, uh, you know,
telling jokes and that type
of shit. Um, I'm sorry.
I guess I need you guys, somebody, people
always ask me how to talk about hoop.
I just can't fucking watch it. I
try, I like college hoops. You know,
I actually was going to watch North
Carolina cause once again they got a great
team. They're fucking ranked second
the fuck it tie heels right in.
I came in there but we, you know, my
wife always sits down and she wants,
she wants to watch a dumb TV. She goes,
can you just sit down and watch dumb TV?
Is that fucking Kardashians Shit?
Which has been on a God damn loop
that shit the other day. Okay. And um,
it was on, you know, they
got an f episodes now.
It's like the fucking Simpson's whether
you can just do a whole weekend of
nothing but the Simpsons,
you can do that with the Kardashians.
Not so she just kept watching them
and watching them and I literally,
I had to get up and walk into the bedroom
and closed the door. It that the show,
it literally puts me in a fucking
bad mood. Um, I know that there's a,
there's a clip I just saw on
Facebook. Of course, I'm on Facebook.
I'm a white gay in my forties.
I love Facebook as much
as the youngsters hate it.
Everything they hate about it. I
fucking love about it. But anyways,
this some local news show or whatever,
and this guy just,
he just fucking sums up.
He snaps.
He completely loses his
composure and just says like,
nobody gives a fuck about this
stupid fucking family. And the,
these two chicks laughing, one of
them agrees and then the other like,
just breathe. Just breathe.
Like that makes it better.
It's like just enough already.
I,
my, my wife has it on so
much. I'm actually starting
to understand like the dude,
you know who looks like a fucking
mannequin, he's got perfect hair,
perfect white teeth. He's always walking
around in a suit, but he's never at work.
And I finally just sit there. I go, what
the fuck does that guy do for a living?
And they're like, eh. You know, nobody
really knows. Nobody knows what he does.
You know? He's always walking around like
a dress like Bud Fox, and then I'm like,
oh my God, I'm getting sucked
into this thing. So I just,
I just went into the other room.
It's just an endless fucking pursuit.
They just constantly traveling.
I love like when they go to
the Dominican Republican,
did they interact with the people?
They go right to the fucking resort
and there's sitting next to a fucking
infinity Paul. You know what I mean?
It's just, it's like, why did you,
why did you just stay home? You already
live in that climate. You're dumb fucks.
Let me tell you about the time I
went to the Dominican Republic.
I went there and they took us nice, oh
fuck, fuck. Get that mother. Fuck you fat.
Fuck, it's not yours. Goddamn that
fat fuck. He landed right on it.
Okay.
Probably thought it was a pork shoulder.
Oh Great. When we get hurt. Wonderful.
Ah, for fuck sakes. Anyways, so
I got to Dominican Republic, um,
with the wonderful lady
I was dating at the time.
Fuck that relationship up as I did
everyone and until I met my lovely wife,
um, and we stayed at a resort, right?
We show up and I got there. And what
then? Too far like east, you see what,
how people are living as you drive
in there and you're like, holy fuck.
It was my first time and I a
so called Third World country.
I didn't know what the fuck that means.
It just always means it's a bunch of
broke people. I don't, I don't know.
Fucking like staggering. You know,
I saw a couple of nice
houses and everything else.
It was like a fucking tin shack and
we're fucking blowing by all this poverty
and you're taking it all in.
It's an absolute shock when you're
spoiled ass fucking American.
All right,
now I'll give a fuck what your situation
is in this country for the most part,
you'll live in like a fucking king
compared to this stuff, right?
So we end up getting to the resort and
then all of a sudden everybody has only
these fucking Hawaiian shirts saying
hello, asking to take your bags.
And it's like,
well,
am I supposed to forget what the fuck
I just saw still the entire time I'm on
this a vacation.
What's funny about the resort is this,
like literally like a prison wall all
the way around the whole fucking thing.
And he just feel it.
You just felt it like late at night.
If I get too close to that wall,
somebody is going to reach over.
It yanked be over it and no one's ever
going to see me again because that's the
level of desperation down here.
And um,
my favorite part slash the
scariest part of the trip was a,
we actually went horseback riding and we
went to a, a cave where there was water.
You went to the water and he had to go
underwater and then come up to the other
side of the different cave. I know this
sounds like a fucking hardy episode,
but we actually did it and I remember,
uh,
the tour guide,
the tour guide that took us,
I had to stop at his fucking house.
So I am sitting there and
the front passenger seat
of his car as everybody is looking at me,
basically the widest motherfucker
on the planet. And, uh,
and I had to sit there like,
are they looking at me like Jesus Christ?
How often do you see a redheaded white
dude down here where they looking at me
like a white elephant? Oh, are they
looking at me like a, you know,
God knows what our foreign policy did
then. Now they're in that situation.
I had no fucking idea,
but it's definitely a,
I dunno, I, but I was
glad, still glad I did it.
I still went out to interact that it
actually gave the horseback thing and the
Cave Shit, I actually was given money to
people outside of that fucking resort.
It just, it didn't feel right.
Does that make any sense?
I don't fucking know watching the
fucking game here. But anyways, um,
nay, I'm talking about
the Kardashians. I late,
they go to all these impoverished places
and they just still end up next to an
infinity pool, which to me is
like, why the fuck would you leave?
You're not interested cause she'd
starving and he got food. Right. Okay.
She just went like 20 fucking times.
Um,
she asked me a win.
This game was going to be over
because she wanted to watch dumb TV.
And I was like, I wanted to be like,
we know what this is my dump TV.
This is my keeping up with the
Kardashians. I watched the Patriots.
Come on Neil, look at Tom
Brady. Isn't he dreamy?
He looks like that guy with no job on
the, uh, the Kardashians, doesn't he?
Except he's a man. Um, anyways, so,
uh,
today in New York,
I actually went to the premiere of a
movie called Daddy's home starring Mark
Wahlberg and uh,
will Ferrell it a,
that comes out and then go on Christmas
Day. And if you blink, you'll miss me.
I have a small part in and
I got to go there, EH, fuck.
Alegria Yard my way through this whole
fucking thing. I imagine I am. Um,
oh first he's on his way verse.
He's on his way. I think I'm in.
This is going to be a two parter. There's
going to be the first part I do today.
You know what? Who's kidding
who? This point, you know what?
This podcast just became late.
I was hoping I could finish this
thing before verse he got here.
I got media all day tomorrow and I told
Paul is going to go out and go get a
beer with them.
I'm going to do that so nia can watch
dumb TV and we'll go out to a bar.
I'm going to watch the rest of the game
there. I confess, but you know what?
I did make the pie crust video. I
hope it helped you guys out. And uh,
it's got over 600,000 hits that fucking
pikers videos got more hits than most of
my specials.
And this week I actually finally was able,
those ribs that I was smoking I was
telling you about, they came out fucking,
and what I learned was it doesn't
matter at least on the green egg,
the big green egg, like, uh, as long as
you got smoked that first hour and a half,
something like, um, ribs. Not,
I'm a total fucking novice.
This is a second time ever tried it.
It's the first time I ever
did it successfully. Uh,
the other time I had to finish him off
in the oven, which isn't necessarily bad.
Um,
oh good.
Nia just got fucking two ply toilet paper.
Three ply.
You got the most ply toilet
paper, right? Oh my God.
I can't tell you who stayed here.
I'm not going to tell you stayed here,
but he stayed here and he fucking
loaded this place up. It's not even,
it's not even one ply toilet paper. It's
like literally almost see through, um,
I don't know what he was trying to do,
but all I know is I would rather wipe
my ass with sandpaper there. I said it.
All right. Look, I understand if you're in
a financially rough place, but you know,
can you put a price,
you know what I mean?
I might as well take
a belt sander the car.
Yeah,
there's a crack of my ass. It's like,
what are we doing here? You know,
it's very easy to go steal some
Kleenex out of these fucking stores,
give you ass a fighting chance.
Anyways.
Um,
so I found what the big green egg,
what I did was, uh, I followed all the,
the videos basically of how to
start the fire. One of these guys,
they always make these fucking videos
on how to smoke something and all they
talk about is there rubs and
how long they leave it in there.
And the most important fucking thing
on the big green egg is do what is your
fire look like? What's
the percentage, you know,
those burned up fucking coals versus
your year, your wood. So I did,
uh,
I did like half of that or not the shit
that's got the chemical on it before.
Everybody gives me a rough time.
It's the shit that looks like how a
tree looks when it's in the middle,
after a forest fire and it's put out.
I use that natural shit.
And then I had these big blocks
of Hickory that I'm told,
it doesn't make a difference if you soak
them or not. Um, so I didn't soak those,
but then I had a bunch of those,
just the chips that you soak overnight.
I soak those things overnight and I had
an insane amount of smoke for the first
about hour and a half of the cook.
And um,
I kept it roughly at about two
50 the entire time. And uh,
some people might think that's a little
high. I don't know what they came up.
So rather than doing it for four hours,
I took it out about three 43
45 they came out great. A Post,
a couple of pictures of it, but, uh,
one of the most exciting parts of my week
was Nia tried them and came out to the
kitchen and fucking high five me and
did a little dance. It's the fuck was,
you know what the, that was the highlight,
you know, cause I know we don't,
I made the ribs and he
actually enjoyed them.
No, no, but I was trying something new.
All right, thank you. Do you know what,
there's one of the little,
sometimes you just know when
you're not supposed to talk to you.
I fry now she's focused on something else.
So maybe I know it the shit out of
her earlier. I have no fucking idea.
But let's get all of the budget's been
like fucking running my yap here. Let's,
uh, what do we got now? I've got to
type in the fucking password. Go.
Uh, Jesus Christ. What?
You know what I love?
How fucking difficult you have to make
these fucking pot, these a passwords.
You know what I mean? Like, do you have
like governmental secrets in here? Um, oh,
Friday night or Saturday nights,
you guys watch the fucking UFC.
How insane with those fights?
I don't know anybody's fucking name.
How do they go on? I'm at Greg. Um, did
you see that one fight? That dude was,
he was like this. I didn't know
what the fuck to call the guy.
He's got to have some sort of nickname.
He just got on this guy's back
and he wouldn't get off of him.
Every time he did like go to shake
them off, he'd keep getting back on.
I mean it's like, you know you ever
have like a fucking, I don't know.
Your fingers are wet and you pick up a
hair and you're trying to get it off.
You've got to wipe it on something else
and then somehow it just comes back to
you. You know what I was like, can
you take out cellophane but whatever.
The dead Saran wrap shit,
it just starts sticking to
itself and he tried to fucking,
I get and do what I can save it. I can
save in the, I have to fuck this piece.
Right. That's what he was, he
was like the human version.
That's not a good nickname
for fucking a fighter. Is it
human cellophane?
I don't think that's too intimidating.
He was just on this fucking guy and that
dude could not get them off and he was
named after it was Gunnar Nelson
for half a second.
I thought he was the son of the Nelsons
who are the son of Ricky Nelson who went
to that garden party, right. To
reminisce with his old friends.
Remember that I went to a garden party,
reminisce with mild France.
Do you like Ricky Nelson?
Nia.
Yeah.
You like the simplicity of
those old songs. The sound,
the sound of thunder in the background.
That's one of my gloves.
Come over here and talk to
me for two seconds. Let me
sing you some Ricky Nelson.
Maybe. Maybe this, this'll, this'll ring
a bell. Hang on one second. Hold on.
Hey Forsee. Where are
you at? All right, dude.
I'll be downstairs in like 10 minutes.
I'm wrapping up my podcast where
the first half of it or, right.
Okay.
All right buddy. I'll see you in a
minute. All right, bye. All right.
Let me send you a little bit of Ricky
Nelson. Maybe this Ricky Nelson is,
I know who his sons are. They had long,
blonde hair. Do you know the songs?
No,
it was probably like,
Eh,
like I'm talking and I'm talking
about his dad dead dad. Oh yeah.
He was some like,
oh,
walking is indeed very simple song.
Listen to the rhythm of the fouling.
Rain telling me what a fool I've been.
Yeah.
And then as something got away again,
it's up to an assumpted something.
Okay, Ray, please tell me.
Does she love me? So why are you
talking to me? You know what?
Cause this is my odd ways. Show
showing that I love you. I love, well,
I love you too.
We are torturing me.
I want to eat my Thai food and watch
my dumb TV. I love you very much.
Do you want me to get out of here?
What are you gonna Watch you to watch
the car dash out? It's Sunday night.
It's a big night in reality television.
I need you to leave.
Whereas your question, why
do I always have to get the
fuck put balls? My Dumb TV?
How come I always have to fucking leave?
You know what? That's a great point.
And that's why I love you. Do
you know how few women? Yeah.
If you fucked that cue and beings
can actually be like, you know what?
That's a good goddamn point. Yes, I do.
Yeah,
it is like get out.
Oh, all right. Beat it. I
beat it at, yeah, you paid it.
I'm going to wrap this
up right now and I'm,
I'm Paul [inaudible] waiting for you.
Oh, you're a terrible friend. Yeah.
You know what? You know you're
a terrible person actually.
You're actually concerned
about Paul Versey.
Your first concern is me getting the
fuck out of here so you can watch old
fucking chock teeth there.
Pretend like he has a job.
I Love Barbara Z and I don't want to be
waiting to be waiting around for you.
Very listened to the rhythm
of your fucking bullshit.
Acting like you care about my friends.
You just want me to fucking lead this
place so you can watch those stupid twats
Nini.
Please tell me why you watch that show
something. Something, something
with the mistletoe. I get it.
You have a big round ass stop greasing
it up and putting it on the legacy inc
I'm sorry. All right, I'll
be back. Maybe tomorrow.
We'll finish this fucking thing up.
Jesus Christ. Can you fucking block?
We don't have anybody left.
All right.
I'm going to say that we were
going to fuck this game up.
This is what's going to happen.
They're going to come back.
They're going to make it,
what's it 20 to 60?
That's going to be 20 to 20 and we're
going to have to drive down the fucking
field and hopefully a kick another
long field golf. Jesus Christ,
they all spin. Move. Good
Lord. He didn't even touch him.
All right, I'll talk to you
guys in a minute. Well, you
know, it'd be two seconds.
All right?
Okay.
All right. Anyway, so as I was
saying, as I was saying, um,
it's still Sunday night, the Patriots
fucking win and it'd been 27 to six. Okay.
So I overreacted. You know, what do you
want from me? So what did I leave off?
I left off with the human cellophane,
right?
I was talking about those fights.
I saw, um, the fucking guy,
let me,
let me back pedal the hell was a gunner.
Nelson couldn't get the
human cellophane off of.
And then there was the guy who fought
the guy who comes in like a spider and he
stuck his face out and got knocked out
and then he kicked him in the leg and
broke his leg.
That fucking guy fought Jesus Christ.
I don't think I've ever seen a guy
get hit that many times in the head.
I thought the fight, I thought
the fight was over. I didn't know.
I didn't realize that the referee
jumped in because the round ended,
but he took the, there was like a
fucking watching like a rocky fight.
You know when you watch a
rocky fight going to do,
there's no way anybody could take that
many shots to the head. You'd be dead.
You'd be on your ass to the fight would
be over. This fucking guy took it. Um,
I don't know what I'm saying.
I didn't ever know the names.
And then the bird can guide their fucking
a Conor McGregor who's fighting as
Brazilian dude. He's got this crazy scar
and the, he's already Brazilian Sarah.
I already know. He sees a
fucking nightmare. He's going
to take it to the ground.
You're fucked.
Right.
Was he not kicking people in
the phase to this guy? He would.
He could kick your ass. No. Oh
yeah. Why don't give a shit.
You're sitting in a chair or
fucking running down the sidewalk.
He's one of those guys. The guy can,
he can't kick the shit out of it.
So I've taken, wow man, this is going
to be a fucking unbelievable test form.
Hey Fuck. Any just ran right
at him. The ball wrenched up.
Yeah.
And I kinda did the old right there.
Fred Bam guides is a face plant he took
to a judge's decisions to the face after
their, whatever, their hammer fist.
So what is that, what they call it?
Took the old gavel
to hits the gavel and that was it.
It was fucking over. And um, I, like
other guys said afterwards, he goes,
you know, we've got to fight
again. That wasn't really a
fight. It's like, no. Well,
it was a fight. You got
knocked out, dude. You know,
that usually indicates that was some
sort of a fight. It's like, you,
you fucking slipped.
And fell and he had on a desk.
There was no desk in that octagon. That
was a, uh, that was his left hand. Um,
but Jesus Christ, man,
that was fucking amazing.
I was actually talking to some of the
guys I was watching the fight with. I go,
how much tension is going to be in
Dana White's house over Christmas?
If Conor McGregor loses too
after fucking what's her face?
Lost female, female Tyson, right?
Then you're going to have Irish Tyson.
If they both go down,
then who you're going to,
who's going to fucking sell a fight?
You need them the way they talk. Shit.
The how much fucking money is sitting in
fucking Dana of mine that's sitting in
data white sock drawer right now because
you got to fucking amazing athletes
like that who also not a sell a fight.
You know what I mean?
There's deaf other guy won 90 to get.
Now you get a guy who needs a fucking
interpreter for me to understand it,
to sell the goddamn fight.
It's over.
I don't even like fucking
watching movies with subtitles.
I gotta I gotta fucking, I got to deal
with the guy that he's got to have a,
you know,
he's typing a fight.
I look like I'm watching a senator
testifying is fucking lawyer keeps coming
over whisper in his ear. I
don't want to see that. Right.
I don't even know what I'm
saying here. Um, anyway,
so I forgot to tell you guys this shit.
I almost forgot this fucking story.
So I've been trying to work out
when, uh, when I've been here,
two or three days I've worked out,
right? So we go to the gym the first day,
it's right down the street from my
apartment. There's no fucking problems.
I walk in, the guy behind the counter
is cool. There's nobody else there,
no manager. Just some cool guy goes,
hey, by the way, it's 15 bucks.
But if you go on the Internet
and you look this shit up,
it only costs you five bucks.
I said, dude, I'm old. I
suck at the Internet. Okay.
Just generally speaking, I'm not good in
that. He goes, I'm just saying, you know,
it's money. And I was like, Hi man, I'll,
I'll try to find the fucking page
and I'll come back the next day.
I'll only pay five bucks. So he goes,
cool, no problems, no fucking problems.
I have a great workout. I fucking troll
the weights around. Classic Shit Comedian.
I go to the gym in the middle of the day.
It's great.
There's nobody fucking there.
Okay.
A couple of trophy wives on treadmills,
you know,
fucking looking at their Instagram as
they walk fucking half a mile an hour and
then you come walking in and I don't give
a fuck what time of day you walk into
a gym.
If you have to do chest that date this
to all the benches are going to be taken
up. You know what I mean?
Nobody's ever doing squats.
You can walk into a gym Saturday,
fucking Saturday.
Like what's,
what's a busy like early in the
morning when people come in, wherever,
19 when it would have fucking the
busiest time right after work.
Six o'clock at night.
Okay.
You can go walk into a gym and you can
just immediately just start doing squats.
Nobody's ever done. Nobody does
fucking legs. Everybody does the bench.
So I walk into this five people,
they have three benches,
there's like five people working out.
Three of them are guys fucking
bench pressing God damn consul.
I get to sit there and pretend
like I'm fucking really stretching.
I'm not really stretching. I'm
waiting for you to finish, right?
So anyways,
that was the first day.
So the second day I go to go
back and Oh my God, here we go.
You know I'm going to run into
this guy again. He's going to say,
how can we didn't get the fucking thing
that only makes you pay five bucks and
be like, because I suck at the Internet.
Remember I'll pay 15 I don't give a fuck.
Right? And I come showing
up, he's not there.
There's some lady there and then this
fucking manager buzzing around, hey,
how long you in town for Josie?
Good membership level. I said, no,
do I just want to work out today? He
goes, all right, fill out this form.
So it's name, address,
phone number, email,
all of this shit.
So I write down a fake name and I say
I'm from Alaska and that's it, right?
So he goes, no, I'm sorry,
so you've got to fill out the rest of
this where all the addresses now all I had
to do, which just fell out
of fucking fake address,
but you know it's not how I'm wired.
I got to make a point. I go, dude,
I have to give you my home
address. He goes, yes, I go to a,
I'm not trying to be a jerk, but I'm
not going to give you my home address.
Am I going to tell you where I live
so I can work out one day at a gym?
And he goes, well, you know you have
to fill it out a little. And I go, why?
Why do you need to know where I live? And
he hems and haws and I just keep going.
Why do you need to know where I
live? Okay, it's $15 to work out.
I have the $15 I'm going to give it to
you and I'm going to work out at the gym.
Why do you need to know where I live?
So finally goes, well, sure, you know,
God forbid if you have some sort of
incident happens and we need to get in
contact with somebody.
I said,
so you're telling me that God
forbid to use your expression,
God forbid I Keel over on the elliptical,
you're going to,
you're not going to dial nine one one
you're going to go drive to my house and
knock on the door and hope somebody there.
That's what you're gonna do.
You're not going to do that. He's going
to call nine one one like everybody else.
He just keeps going, well, well, you know,
what are we going to contact? It's like,
what the fuck do you care who to contact?
You know, eight I just said, look,
if you could tell me why I need
to put down my home address,
okay,
I'll write it down by the,
now I'll give you a phone
number of somebody to call
if something happens to me,
but don't call them. They're not a doctor.
Call nine one one tell you what. Yeah,
that's the deal. Call nine one
one and here's a number. You know,
if you want to let my wife know
where the hell I'm going, that's it.
You don't need to know where I live
to. The guy finally goes, what?
You have to fill it out. And
I go, why? And he goes, it's
protocol. And I go, exactly.
You cannot logically defend
why you want my home address.
You get in my home address.
So the people in corporate
will have that information.
They can sell it to other people, right?
So I go, I'm not working out here, right?
So I would go to walk away and then
the lady behind the desk, she goes,
have a nice day, sir. And
I'll say anything, keep
walking to the bus. She goes,
have a nice day, sir. And I turn
around and go, I understand sarcasm.
Get not telling me to have a nice day.
You're telling me to go f myself.
I got in the elephant.
I know a lot of you guys like to,
why don't you just fucking do you write
a fake address? That's what I fuck.
You know why? Cause at some point
there's gotta be some sort of pushback.
Somebody has to fucking
complain about this shit.
When you walk into those places
and they go, do you have an id?
Don't ever hand them your Id.
You're holding
and just say, here you go.
I'll hold a wrap your fucking
face. You want to read it?
Go ahead and read it. She not type it
and shit from my id onto my Auntie,
your fucking computer. Every time you
put down my name and my address yet sets,
you've added another layer where I
am vulnerable, Thai identity theft.
And I'm not going to do that just
to go work out at a fucking gym.
I'm not having a kidney transplant.
You con I'm going to go
do some fucking pull ups.
Okay.
Give you all my fucking information. I
know you guys probably think I'm a psycho,
right? I'm not. I'm right.
I'm right on this one.
I'm wrong about a lot of other shit.
Okay.
Whatever. This is stupid me. Just sit
here and tell you that I'm writing.
I'll really build. Do you agree
with yourself? That's amazing.
Um,
anyway,
so we don't just want to say I have
fucking worst goddamn stupid cab driver
today. Fucking jump in this fucking
thing, right? We're coming from the, uh,
the premiere, right? So you don't need,
it's gonna fucking high heels on it.
She's not a quitter.
So she's keeping those on and I'm not
going to make her walk with heels on.
What am I a fucking animal,
right?
So we get in this cab when
we fucking drive down,
and this son of a bitch drives
right down fifth avenue,
fifth avenue during Christmas where every
mouse breathe and fucking moron wants
to stand there and look at the Christmas
tree that people skating. Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. And he drives down. Then all
of a sudden you can't make a right.
This guy's acting like he's dumbfounded.
He can't fucking believe it.
And then he ends up cutting over
through fucking times square.
He did everything but try to go through
the Lincoln tunnel to drive like fucking
10 blocks over. Um, and
I was sitting there. Um,
I get aggressively exhaling
the way that,
the only way I could put it and my
wife, she's just fell asleep. She just,
that's something I could do about it.
And she just took a nice nap, you know?
I wish I could be more like
that. Um, all right. Anyways,
let me, yeah, let's start
reading. Oh, you know what?
I haven't done any advertising
for this week. Have I?
I read some of these stupid fucking thing.
So who's getting it?
Why don't I make an attempt?
All right. Uh, oh Jesus. Great.
Boop, boop, boop. Me. Andy's, I can't sing
too loud because it's late at night here,
but I brought up, yeah, Andy's me undies.
Sticky balls in the snow boot doot doot
me on days we undies now that cold day,
you go take them out,
put on the undies.
Now they're all dry and they feel
nice and soft. You balls are so great.
Don't forget about your te Dan.
You're assholes come into, oh yeah.
When you have the undies,
your crotch feels great.
Even if you're a fucking wrestling and
somebody gives you the fish hook and the
butthole me undies.
We all know how sexy confidence can be
and that confidence comes from being
comfortable.
But how great can you feel if your
underwear's Franklin or riding up beyond
Andy's gets it?
And that's why they've created the
world's most comfortable underwear for a
daily dose of confidence. Uh,
you wear underwear every day.
That's turned 65 days a year.
Rain or shine.
You need it to be extraordinary
without an insane price. Tag me.
Andy's understands this and that's
why they've created the world's most
comfortable underwear. Luxury at half the
retail price you'll find anywhere else.
When you look good, you feel great. It's
a Cliche, you know, why? Cause the stroke,
the,
he's understands this and that's why they
designed underwear that makes you look
and feel fantastic. Um, no.
Modelle is pronounced modal. Mandy's
is made for modal, modal, modal,
my mantle a fabric that's
twice the softest cotton.
That's twice as soft as whatever
underwear you're wearing right now.
Unless you already have a
pair of me undies on me.
And he says tons of colors and styles
and then the only place to get matching
pairs from men and women.
If you're that pussy whipped,
they even rely released
a new design every month.
I wear whatever free pair they fucking
get me. My balls have never been happier.
Plus we all know that paying
for shipping sucks, man,
so me and he said remove
that from the equation.
All orders in the U S and Canada
ship for free me and he says,
even as even has a money back guarantee.
If you know like your first pair,
you get to keep it for free.
You'll literally have nothing to lose
and you get a free pair of underwear a to
sweeten the deal.
Mandy's is offering you 20% off your
first order at [inaudible] dot com slash
bird that's a special offer for just my
listeners or word or wherever else they
advertise.
Make sure you go to [inaudible] dot com
slash bird and get 20% off your first
order and so that they know we sent you.
All right.
MVMT watches movement.
Watches was started by two college
dropouts with the idea to make quality
watches that don't break the bank
starting at just 95 bucks and sold online.
They cut out all the
bullshit retail markup.
A supposedly movement sent some
watches over here. Yeah, they did.
And I got a man that fucking
sweet. They're nice. You know,
you put them on. No one can tell it. It's
a fucking $95 watch. They'll be like,
holy shit.
Is that a $950 watch?
Um, what do you do for a living?
Quality materials and sleek designs.
So perfect everyday watch. It's easy
order online today for free shipping.
Free returns at a 24 month warranty.
These are not cheap watches.
If they guaranteeing them for two years.
A smart looking watches,
nice clean design.
Join the movement and say no to the
big brand retail markups and say yes to
great style.
Checkout MVMT watches.com/burr and
you'll get 15% off your entire purchases.
Uh, that's Mike Victor, Mike Tango,
watches.com/ [inaudible] all right,
stamps.com everybody. Oh God,
this was the last one. Um, okay.
stamps.com everyone,
you know with the holidays almost here,
you don't have time to go to the
post office to yet traffic parking.
It will be packed with everyone.
Mailing holiday gifts, some packages.
So do what I do.
Use stamps.com stead with stamps.com you
can avoid all the hassles of going to
the post office man during
the busy holiday season.
Everything you would do at the
post office, you know what?
You can do it right from
your own God damn desk.
Buy and print official US postage
using your own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter or
package the instance you need it.
Then the mailman picks it up.
It's so easy and convenient.
I use stamps.com to send out all my
posters whenever I'm whoring myself out
after my shows. I'm a moron
if I can do it. So can you,
and you should right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last
name bur bur for this special offer,
a four week trial, a $110 bonus offer,
including postage and a digital scale.
Don't wait, go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter
burr.
Um,
by the way that I mentioned how much
frigging money we raise for all those
people we raised like over 10 grand.
All right.
And I'm going to throw a nice fucking
chunk of change in on top of that.
You guys did a wonderful thing
and uh, it amazes me, man, that I,
I did this podcast this long
and I didn't realize that a,
you could make an impact
like that. So, uh,
you guys were all part of a great thing
and I really appreciate how much you
guys all stepped up. You were very,
very generous, extremely generous.
Um, you know, it's not even Christmas
yet. You already did your good deeds.
So now you know you didn't get spike the
Eggnog, you can get hammered, you know,
and treat the people and it family like
shit. Right? Take them for granted.
Fuck them. Right? That's
what they get for showing up.
They knew what they were in for,
how many Christmases that they got to
spend with you before they realize what
you're going to be doing. Um,
alright, let's read some letters. Hey,
this one might be a little short because
it's already one in the morning and I
got to be on the fucking radio
at 7:00 AM oh Jesus. Oh Jesus.
All Right, tool for the egg.
Hey Bill, I've been running,
running an egg for several years now.
Your podcasts about no smoke
on ribs had me captivated.
I would suggest my tool to
stir up the coals and bring,
bring into context slash smoking hardwood
chips slash chunks kind of fucking
sentences that I would suggest my tool
to stir up the coals and bring into
contact slash smoke and hardwood chips.
Slash chunks.
That's a fucking cent.
You know something I would suggest getting
off a sentence tool. How about that?
They still make that hooked on
phonics and way back in the day,
there was a classic stand up,
a reference us simply purchase a piece
of three by 16 by 36 pieces steal from
home depot, Home Depot
place, and Ben 90 degrees,
two inches from the end.
Use this to unplug slash stir the coals
from the inward vent on the bottom of
the egg. Ah, okay.
I will utilize this tool during long
smoking to invigorate the smoke.
This also works to bring air oxygen to
the fire to increase the temperature.
Simply Polk,
who several of the fire,
great holes at the bottom of the egg
to increase the air flow. Ah, okay.
Do you have any issues
or just need a pick?
Just ask the least I
can do for your podcast.
So why didn't you fucking send a picture?
Now you've got to sift through
a thousand fucking emails. Now,
you know what I did was I
layered in some charcoal,
then they had the chips
with the chunks of Hickory,
and then I did another
layer on top of that,
and then I just put in one
little firestarters square
and I did it from the side.
So it just slowly burned across and down.
It was plenty for ribs,
but like if I was ever going to do a
pork shoulder, we, you know, you talking,
I don't know how long,
it depends on how big it is,
but it seems on average people that
that's like six to 10 hours to God knows
what. So that, I don't know how
I would continue to do that,
but I think I would just take it off and
I'd lift the grate, the plates center,
and I would just throw the shit
in there and then put it back on.
I think it would be fine.
Um, that's what I would do.
You know what the reality is when I just
buy a fucking smoker and be done with
it. All right. Traveling with girlfriend,
slash. Fiance. Hey Billy board.
Dane.
I have to disagree with your advice from
last week for the guy with the sound
engineering job.
He said he was a sound engineer
in the letter you read out loud.
Then later in your response you mentioned
something about building bridges and
then again on Twitter. Just a heads up
dude, this guy is fucking relentless.
Some of you guys, you fucking relentless
like reprimanding me. All right,
so I fucked this fucking thing
up, so let me guess. Okay,
well I think if he's planning on Spi,
I like how you think that being a sound
engineer, even though I fucked it up,
like that's not a,
that's not a quality job.
You know what I mean? What do you know
what to, you would be working in films,
right? Isn't that what that
job is? Recording bands.
That's a fucking great job and
it's a hard, you know what?
I'm going to look it up right now
before I get another fucking 20 God damn
tweets and emails from you.
Sound engineer.
Yeah.
And audio engineer working with tentacle
aspects of sound during the process of
recording, mixing and reproduction
audio engineers often with sisters,
record producers and musicians to help
give their work to sound they are hoping
to achieve. Yeah, that's a fucking
bad ass job that people want to do.
All right, let me get
back here. So here we go.
I think if he's planning on spending
his life with this girl traveling and
having a great time would be a
make or break deal for marriage.
She said she wanted to travel a year,
suppose it's only seven months and they
go to seven continents even go to us and
we'd go to the fucking Antarctica.
Okay. Over the course of a year,
they get to bang in seven continents
in a year, eat amazing food,
see amazing things and pretty much
lived their lives like it's a movie.
You looked at the negative side,
which is fair,
but also how often did
these things happen?
I hate to be the guy that didn't take
that chance. If it were presented,
God knows I would.
Of course.
It all depends on their attitudes and
if they're fun people with positive
outlooks and good communication,
food for thought, hey dude,
just because I don't agree with you
doesn't mean I want the negative route.
I was giving him advice from my hat,
which is fucking positive.
I'm saying he's got a great job that
he was nervous about fucking leaving.
Those are his words,
not mine to then to end.
This is another thing too, dude.
You're a fucking man. Okay?
If you're not making money,
it's now that he can make a baby other
than dump your Jizan somebody you need up.
Like women can literally create life.
Okay?
You liked the butter
and the fucking pants.
I Dunno. Maybe I'm old school. I feel
like the man should make a fucking living.
You've got to come home and you got to
make enough money that you're a woman in
your family is fucking comfortable
and if you're doing that,
you're a fucking man.
All right?
If you want to go travel around the world
on some woman's fucking dime and leave
your career behind for a fucking year,
a critical God damn year and
have to start all over again.
I think that's nuts.
Yeah,
I think that's fucking nuts.
All right. Agree to disagree.
I can tell you this dude,
when I started out doing stand up,
I was doing this shit
every single fucking night.
Every night I had a singular focus.
What I was trying to do was a job
that a lot of people would like to do.
So it took a ridiculous level of
commitment and I watched people who didn't
fucking traveled the world,
didn't even have that fucking option,
but I watched people not work at it
as hard as they could have in 20 years
later. I see the results
of that. So that's all I'm
saying with this guy to, uh,
you know, to put play before
work is just not how I'm wired.
You know what I mean? Um, you
making it seem like this guy,
if he takes the sound engineering job,
will never have the money or
never have the option to do,
to go around and travel the world.
I Dunno.
I just feel like as as me personally,
if I was going to travel the world,
it's got to be on my fucking dime,
okay.
In my eye and my life has to be in a
place where I can leave it for a fucking
year. If I'm just getting started in a
career and I'm just starting to push that
fucking rock up the hill and I'm going
to go fucking leave and play footsie with
some chick even she's going to be the
chicken I'm going to fucking marry for an
entire Goddamn year, then I'm going to
come back and start all over again. Um,
I would be going out of my fucking mind.
I had to be honest with the two.
Uh,
as much as I've traveled,
there's always a point and it's usually
anywhere between seven to 10 days ended
the trip where I just want to go home.
I want to sleep my own bed.
I want to be fucking, you
know, hanging out with my dog
and not to mention that I love being
a comedian. I want to do some shows.
It's fun.
So agree to disagree.
Agree to disagree. All
right, food for thought.
Did you typed out wearing a sweater
with candles on in the background?
Candles on candles lit. Okay. He
said and go to Cape Carp Yourself.
Car Pay I don't want to do is go sees
yourself like car paid diem. Okay,
go carpet K.
I just can't bear to have you not get
the reference and hope someone writes in
about it next week. Sorry. Thanks.
Oh go car. Pay Yourself. Oh, I thought
it said go to carpet. Go carper yourself.
Carpe Diem. Yeah. See I
love how seize the day is.
Just fuck off to your life and go travel
around the world and like seize the day
isn't like,
you know what,
I've made inroads in this really difficult
line of work and I'm going to stick
with this dude. I fucking,
you know something.
I started out with comics who did that
and stayed home with their family and
watch the fucking patriots game instead
of going out and going and doing a hell
Gig. I'm telling you, it
all fucking matters. It all
matters. Wait, why would I know?
What the fuck do I know? You know,
I did it the way I did it. I'm not,
I'm I,
yeah,
but fucking traveling the world
on somebody else's inheritance.
Kind of a fucking Bama.
My,
I'm not fucking doing that of one of my,
you know what,
I'll do that if you get me a pair of
fucking gold digger and pumps and I'll
fucking walk that walk around in
those all God damn year. Well,
I want to travel the world.
I'm fucking pay for it. Um,
I think that says something about you
too. If you feel like you, you know,
you don't have any problem going around
the fucking world on somebody else's
dime, I want to earn it. All right.
Face of sponsorship. Uh,
Billy Butterworth. Uh,
would you ever do a major
sponsorship for a big brand?
What are your thoughts in the
following coke, Pepsi chilies.
Sizzler Wilson tennis rackets or
I guess I'm doing it right now.
Um, what I, I mean though,
it's more with they. Um, and
how long would it last? I mean,
I can't even get these fucking jerk off
podcast advertisers to stick with me.
They're so fucking dumb.
They don't realize that if I fuck around
and I curse and I be a fucking idiot,
you guys actually will listen to it.
My philosophy is just cause I'm reading
advertising doesn't mean the show stops
if to show stops and he just pat
you just fast forward through it.
It's so fucking simple.
The such idiots that don't see that about
our product people and start believing
it like, like you guys
actually take anything that
I say seriously. Um, anyways,
plowing ahead here girl.
Quit Job Lady.
This lady quit her job
and traveled the world.
Um, all right, here we go. My girl quit.
My girl comes home.
Why don't you feel like there
was something else in there?
Did I miss one of these
things? Maybe not. Right.
My girl comes home early the other
day and tells me she quit her job.
I worked full time in a metal shop.
Jesus Christ would be a blacksmith.
And I go to school full time
for engineering. Uh, we also
have two beautiful kids.
We cannot afford our houses, our houses,
cars, et Cetera, without her working.
And she acts like I'm a bad guy.
When I say when I get on or about it.
Oh Jesus.
I don't know what I should do.
I'm thinking of leaving her because this
is not the first time she's done this.
And then the total seven
years we've been together,
she's worked about two and a half feet,
two and a half years of around 10 jobs.
Wait, she has worked about two and a
half years of around 10 jobs. You mean?
And I'm guessing you're saying she said
10 jobs and collectively work two and a
half years. Can't take the financial
stress anymore. What's your advice?
Um, uh, first thing I would do,
I have downsize your life.
Yeah.
Just be like, all right, well look, if
you're not going to work, then we got,
we got to do something here. Um,
that's incredibly selfish. And, um,
look, she obviously doesn't want
to work. She wants to be at home.
She wants to be with the kids. So you
need to make enough money to basically,
you know, treat her like a third kid. Um,
so your lifestyle is going to have
to go down then if that's what she,
I would just sit down and be like,
can I shoot question?
Do you want to just stay
home and be with the kids,
you know,
and let her fucking flip out and scream
and yell and all that and just don't
lose your cool. Just say to her,
is that what you want? Okay.
Because I need to know that.
Okay.
So I don't keep thinking that,
that we're going to be dual income and
making financial decisions that way.
I can already tell you right now,
dude,
that the fact that you're working full
time and she's working full time and if
the second she fucking quit,
you're fucked.
Do you guys are living beyond
your lifestyle? Beyond your means?
You shouldn't be living like that.
You.
So you're basically the two of you guys
are spending all the money that you're
making. That's, that's no
way to live. All right.
You need to be,
you need,
you need to downsize
your life is basically,
yet I would drive a Toyota or a Honda.
Those fucking things never die.
I'd get one of those. I
downsize. And then, you know,
I mean, I don't think he just quit on
our relationship and walk out on to kids,
but the stress has to be fucking brutal.
And if she's being a fucking
baby about it, um, you know,
that's, uh, you know, this is one of
these fucking things, say, you know,
be a nice change and one of
those chicks shows, you know,
a four broad sit around and fucking
talking about women's stuff.
They never talk about this type shit.
Cause this,
this would probably be considered
sexist if you brought it up.
That's a hell of a fucking thing
for her to be doing to you.
MMM.
I would just, you just gotta lay it on
the line. Just sit her down and just say,
listen,
is this what you want to do?
MMM,
I need to know that because I'm
not going through this again.
All right.
And I would just say you've had 10
jobs in the last seven years and you've
worked collectively, collectively about
two and a half of those seven years.
Okay. When you quit a job like that,
just quit a job and have no other job.
It puts unbelievable stress
on me and it's not fair to me.
Okay.
So I need to know,
do you not want to work?
Do you just want to stay home
with the kids? Because if you do,
we're going to have to downsize
our lives dramatically.
Okay.
If you want to keep living like this,
you need to get a job.
All right.
And
if she flips out about that type of thing.
MMM.
I mean that's a tough one.
I guess I would be like
yeah,
once she flipped out and be like, all
right, you know, something screaming,
yell and get it out of your system.
But you have 48 hours to sit down with
me and discuss this like an adult and cut
a plant.
Okay.
Or
I need to make a decision.
Okay.
Cause I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna live my life with
this level of financial stress.
MMM.
Something along those lines.
Cause that's how you do what she's doing
to you is unbelievably immature and
fucking selfish. When you need dual
income and you've got two kids at home,
you just don't quit a fucking job.
All right?
Jesus fucking Christ. What if you
did that? You know what I mean?
See I'm telling you this right here.
What'd that fucking guy was sitting
there talking that guy saying like, oh,
you should fucking leave your job and
go travel around the fucking planet.
This is why you don't do that.
What's your doing?
Serb busting your ass trying to get ahead.
That's what you do when you fucking young.
Okay.
It makes your life a hell of a lot
fucking easier and you get older. Okay.
Cause the older you fucking get, you
gotta be somewhere. You know what I mean?
Like the alley. They want to hire young
people generally fucking speaking,
you have to be at, at a certain
place by a certain fucking age,
generally speaking, or they're not
going to give you a shot. Okay.
It's like that old fucking thing about
the fucking, what was it? What was it?
Those two animals,
one of them was stored away food.
The other one was running
around like a fucking jerk off.
And then the storm finally hits in,
the ants fucking eaten.
And then though the turtles, uh, beat
the Hare, however the fucking story goes.
Um,
yeah,
I gotta tell you this,
you know,
I sacrificed lot to get where I'm at
and I missed out on a lot of shit,
but the shit that I on the back end,
then I ended up getting to do okay.
You know,
there was a whole bunch of
stuff that I missed socially,
just fun stuff. So called regular
shit that I missed because,
and I slept on a Futon, like I've told
you a zillion times till I was about 36,
37 years old.
All right?
But
the outside of that was,
I got to perform at Madison Square Garden.
I got to fucking play drums was
slash and duff and guns and roses.
You know what I mean?
It's fucking insane.
But
you gotta be willing to stay on the
fucking Futon till you, you're pushing 40
and laying there in the loneliness of
that with the fucking voices creeping in
your head of doubt. And you have to beat
those things down and said, telling you,
did I did I make a
horrible fucking mistake.
MMM.
So what you're doing sir,
you're working full time and you're going
to school full time for engineering.
Okay?
If you fucking wife,
no offense could just fucking ride
it out for a couple of fucking years.
All right? Until you get your engineering
degree, you get on your fucking feet.
This is what old school
couples used to do. Okay.
They worked more as a fucking
team because generally speaking,
divorce was looked down upon and
they always try to make it look like,
and there was all these women getting
beaten and they just stayed in there like
every fucking woman was getting the
shit slapped out of her. All right.
I'm not saying there wasn't
women getting fucking, you know,
the shit kicked out of them. All right.
But there's a lot of fucking people too,
just to throw in the fucking
towel because it's hard.
And then you're going to get
with somebody else and what?
It's going to be fucking easy. It, it is
hard. But this is, this is like some shit.
You need the iron this out and she
needs to get her fucking head screwed on
straight and realize that she's got his
fucking support you by keeping up her
end of the bullshit while
you become an engineer.
And then you move up the fucking ladder.
And at some point she's going to get
what I think she wants, which is what?
She's going to get to stay home alone.
MMM.
Niggas kick. Can you come over? It
just helped me finish off this podcast.
I know you don't want to your
shoulders blue. He just slumped.
I read this really quickly. I know
you're tired, Nia. We're all tired.
Are you going to sit there like, I'm
going to scold you like a little kid now.
I'm just tired. I know. It's one
15 in the morning. All right.
This guy, uh, his girl
comes home. He's in this,
not even your wife? No. We got two kids.
The girl comes home early the other
day and she tells me she quit a job.
I work full time in a metal shop and
I'm going to engineering school, uh,
going to school time for an engineering.
We also have two beautiful kids.
We cannot afford our houses and our
cars, et Cetera, without her working.
And she acts like I'm a bad guy.
When I say when I get on her about it,
I don't know why I should do,
I'm thinking of leaving her because this
is not the first time she's done this.
And the total seven years
we've been together,
she's worked about two and a half of those
years and had about 10 different jobs.
I can't take the financial stress anymore.
What's your advice? Renee Hill? Yeah,
I mean I think you should definitely
talk to her about it and if you feel like
she's not pulling her weight in your
situation, then that's a problem.
So yeah, it's stressful. If
he's carrying the burden,
they have like two kids and whatever.
I mean,
is she just lying around the house all
day? I mean, is she at least, you know,
taking care of the kids and make sure
they have lunches and all that stuff?
Or is it just all falling on him?
You know? That's really, yeah,
well they need the money. Yeah. All
right, so I'm all right. So, okay. So
if that's what their financial situation
is where they both need to be working
and then they both need to be working,
but I don't know how leaving her is
going to alleviate the financial strain,
but now he's got kids,
he's fucked and then she's going to
bleed them dry because she'd be pissed,
I think. Yeah. I don't know. But
yeah, she needs to get it together.
I'm sorry. Yeah. All right.
All right. I'm sorry. I'm
sorry. Jesus Christ. All right.
Sorry. Why I should have known better
when I asked her since shows loose slumps,
you just literally who came out of the
bedroom to grab something and just going
back to going to sleep in like, Oh, you
want to answer a fucking podcast question?
You see the instincts. I have
people. All right. Listen,
F is for family comes out this Friday,
December 18th for the love of God.
Please sit down and binge watch it.
I know all you star wars fans want to go
see that fucking movie when you're done
seeing that movie, can you please
watch my show? I really appreciate it.
All right. That's the podcast
for Monday. Go fuck yourselves.
Don't take any shit, and I'll tell
I'll check it out on Thursday.